The Babylon 5 reboot looks more and more
likely to be about to happen whether it
be on the CW or HBO Max
so I asked the question to the fans what
would you want to see if it did get a
reboot and you answered
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so before I tell you about some of the
comments I got after I asked this
question first of all I'm gonna try to
answer the very simple question of what
Babylon 5 was
what is the core to this show as well as
what JMS has already said so the
difference between hard and the software
but just really quickly a soft reboot is
like Star Trek the Next Generation the
original series still happened but
you've got whole new characters whole
new story away you go
that's been done any really any sequel
technically if they've got new
characters is a soft reboot a hard
reboot is a new show new characters new
story everything else but the original
series never happened so in this case
JMS is doing a hard reboot I gotta say
first of all I ask the people do you
want a hard reboot and an awful lot of
people said no we'd love a continuation
some people said we want to see Babylon
6. other people and pointed out that you
can't have Babylon six Babylon 5 was our
last best Hope For Peace there were no
other Babylon stations after Babylon 5.
so we can't have a continuation in that
sense we could have seen a continuation
of the story of the Crusades but
that wouldn't have been Babylon 5 either
and JMS has said this will be a Babylon
5 reboot so folks we're getting a reboot
like it or not oh by the way if you do
like the content please consider hitting
the join button and becoming a fully
fledged side tracker you can also go to
sidetrack.com and pick marvelous
merchandise all of these little things
really help the channel also if you're
new to the channel like subscribe hit
that Bell notification and share the
video wherever the hell you want but I
make the Battlestar Galactica comparison
for a very simple reason
Battlestar Galactica worked because it
took the core principles of the original
show the core of what that show was and
it made something new from it so in this
example then we have to think about what
is the core of Babylon five and then
what could JMS use to create an entirely
new show from so for me there are a
couple of really important bits to it
there was the earth membari War I think
that is really key to this it was not
necessarily the war itself but how Earth
reacted to it he is behind me you are in
front of me you value your lives be
somewhere else so we found out that we
were not alone in the universe and we
started to expand and to explore
we came across the membari and a
conflict started
now that was a conflict that we got
soundly beaten during they were on the
brink of wiping us out
now they chose to surrender when they
found out about the whole Souls thing
I also love to prepare how that conflict
started with JMS and but that wouldn't
really be key to me he could think of
something new fat if he wanted to but
the whole way of them they have their
weapon doors open to show this is our
strength but we come in peace and that
scared the human so we fired first we
thought they were threatening us
I liked that story arc and I kind of
hope he can do something similar but
obviously we'll try and do it in a
different way
that was key though it was not like I
say the war necessarily but the defeat
that was important and the way we then
reacted to it and our reaction was to
build the Babylon stations Babylon 5
being the final one a five mile long
space station in neutral space I think
though also not just the fact that the
station was there but it was an
imperfect station you know we had things
like brown sector we had Wanderers
entrepreneurs and diplomats and Hustlers
coming in and out of the station it was
really a hub for aliens to intermix with
each other the good and the bad now
remembering Babylon 5 was considered the
poor man Star Trek back in the day and
it was never very fair example but it
did run roughly at the same time as the
Next Generation the next generation was
all shiny and everything was great and
there's no money and people were perfect
and you know nobody had a dark side
then we have Babylon 5. what actually
did show the underbelly and the reality
of not just humans but of aliens and
life around the universe them in barring
yes were religious anything but even
they have their dark side
a lot of the other alien species were
more like us than we'd like to admit
we then had the shadow War and the
shadow conflict
now
for me the shadow war was the best part
of Babylon 5. it was the third series I
think was the was the best series
um it showed some of the best um amazing
battle scenes and things but the story
was really sharp
um it just it really it for me that was
my favorite part about five is what made
Babylon 5. if you've never watched
Babylon 5 before to be fair you could
just go back and watch the third series
and you'll be absolutely I think it did
after the shadow War sort of meander a
little bit and never quite got back to
that height
even though some of the conflict where
Sheridan had to go and retake Earth and
all that sort of thing was brilliant it
didn't quite have the same punch as the
shadow conflict
so is the shadow war and that whole
thing core to Babylon 5 do they need to
repeat that in the reboot
I'm not sure they do I think the whole
thing between them in Bari and the Earth
Force battle that is key that needs to
be repeated because that is core to why
the Babylon station was then built we
then need to see The Babylon 5 station
or a new modern version of that we then
need to see obviously the aliens coming
together and that's the whole point of
the show
beyond that I think JMS could really do
whatever the hell he wanted
um obviously there has to be some sort
of conflict Susan Ivanova said it best
here the Babylon project was our last
best Hope For Peace but then in the year
of the Shadow War it became something
greater
our last best hope
for victory
the last best hope for survival of
everybody
now
this could mean a new villain we don't
have to necessarily see the Shadows
return even though God I really hope so
they had some of the best Starship
designs I mean the shadows of it oh man
I really want to see that return because
they're iconic but at the same time
James can't really do that again because
we know that story We Know How It Ends
it's got to do something completely
different
now what he has said about his reboot is
that he has seen what lots of other TV
shows have done before him he has
learned himself over many years of
working in the industry
and he has decided that what he wants to
do is is if Babylon 5 never existed if
he had that story today what would he do
him out so that moves me into one of the
other big areas of some of the comments
I saw don't make it go woke a lot of
people do seem to be very nervous that
this show is just going to be another
mess they don't particularly like most
of new Trek I think apart from strange
new worlds new Trek has been a bit of a
failure for me anyway I just don't like
Discovery I wish I did I tried so hard
um but a lot of people do keep using
this word woke now if you are a regular
sidetracker you'll know that I'm not a
fan of that word I do think that there
is a genuine problem with some
filmmakers and that the word woke is
used to describe but Babylon 5 was kind
of a bit woke in the in you know even 25
years ago he did have a lot of
storylines that would be considered now
to be woke you know he did talk about a
lot of very spiritual matters for a
start and religion as well JMS is really
not afraid to explore the issues of the
time he explored not just the good side
of man but the dark side and I think
that exploration would continue within a
new series and to be honest it's got to
because I prefer the word awake I think
all good Sci-Fi should be awake it
should be awake to the day-to-day
problems within our culture and society
and it should explore ways use using the
metaphor of Science Fiction ways to
solve some of those problems
the biggest thing though the biggest
comment I got when I asked people what
do they want to see JMS do with Babylon
5 everybody said we trust GMS give him a
platform don't let interfere and
Executives take over put him on a
network where he can do a good job even
if that has to be the CW a network we
generally don't particularly like
but let him do what he does best and
create a show that we will hopefully
adore almost as much as we adore the
original so guys get in the comments and
tell me what you think what is core to
Babylon 5 what is the important bit that
he must bring into the new series and
what is the stuff that maybe he could
leave behind in the original I'd love to
know exactly what you think and hey if
we shout loudly enough and continuing to
follow the Twitter Trend follow the
hashtag here let's hope that maybe
somebody is listening if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out also if you enjoy the content
please consider becoming a fully fledged
side tracker hit the join button as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time it's over because we've
decided it's over
now get the hell out of our galaxy
[Music]